c'est en quelque sorte leur récompense à
la photo de famille avec le président de
la république ou le métal olympique
brille de tout son éclat
l'athlète valides et handisports ils ont
tous porté haut les couleurs de la
france aux jeux de londres
les représentants héninois y ont
décroché quatre médailles il ne voulait
pas manquer ce rendez vous à l'elysée
oui forcément très important l'elysée
c'est quelque chose de tout nouveau pour
moi c'était la première fois que je
venais donc c'est vrai convient bas
reviennent dans un premier temps en
temps aux curieux et puis on vient dans
un deuxième temps en tant qu'athlète
pour être récompensé par le
un discours de monsieur françois
hollande donc ça c'est toujours quelque
chose de très très émouvant et j'en
profite au maximum et le plus souvent la
médaille est apportée d'objectifs je
peux vous la montrer elle est là donc
voilà vous avez la médaille d'argent des
jeux paralympiques de londres
elle est pas loin parce qu'on me la
demande régulièrement je fais quand même
pas mal de photos avec beaucoup de gens
qui veulent partager des moments avec
cette médaille je pense que c'est quand
même un objet qui est très précieux pour
moi et qui le reste tombe tout au long
de ma vie
après une compétition aussi unique que
les je viens souvent le temps de la
remise en question continuer ou pas de
vivre pour sa passion pour l'instant je
savoure savoir tout ce qui se passe là
tout ce qui m'arrive je vis pleinement
le moment je me pose ensuite je
réfléchis et je prends une décision
ferme et définitive avant les jeux
c'était prévu l'arrêt bien sûr ce que je
m'étais engagé à faire et aujourd'hui je
réfléchis mais c'est normal après un tel
événement on a besoin de se poser un peu
je sais pas répondre à la question
aujourd'hui je encore une fois j'ai
besoin d'entendre réflexion une ou deux
photos souvenirs avant de repartir à
l'entraînement avec pour certains rio
2016 dans un petit coin de la tête